we're done Jennifer Gardner is also
ready to date again after finalizing her
divorce from Ben Affleck yeah and she
looks so radiant last night at the
premiere for hilarious new HBO series
camping it's very funny Jen's big tini
returned 12 years after alias remember
that alongside then rising star Bradley
Cooper
we have a surprise for you an alias
flashback look at this sheriff shows
alias yeah JJ Abrams new pilot look how
cute he is
look at his blond hair you had a chance
to see a stars born earlier cut so proud
of him and it's all we could have told
you then that he would that he would do
what he's doing now
well Bradley's killing it on the big
screen Jen's returned to the small in
camping as insufferable type-a mom
Catherine Jennifer Gardner seems nice
Catherine seems yeah my character was so
mean that I had some making up to do
making up for Jen apparently means
baking up a storm for her co-stars she
showed me what a buckle is do you all
know what a buckle is is it's kind of a
coffee cake we couldn't believe it and
that was like in between her leading
squats and push-ups so Jen garner is
missed
team spirit Juliette Lewis is doing
double duty on TV she's also in the
Conners a couple episodes we shot the
first one I could not believe how homey
it felt unsaid lots of feels on set but
is the network nervous Daily Mail TV
reports to senior ABC execs have regrets
over Roseanne's firing and fear ratings
will freefall without her because quote
what we've discovered is that people
want Roseanne they don't want the family
by themselves ABC spokesperson denies
those are the network's feelings does
anybody even notice how much better the
flow is in this new promo Laurie Metcalf
seems to take over to executive
producers tell variety expect more
changes a dark yet humorous first
episode a new opening sequence
and Roseanne's absence mentioned in
multiple episodes this new clip has a
rather ominous ending dan can I talk to
you for a minute
[Music]
[Applause]